just a disgusting sauce that hurts your
mouth
and probably your stomach and butthole
in just a matter of moments
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Jason Sudeikis you
know him from his decade on Saturday
Night Live Comedy box office smashes
like We're the Millers and horrible
bosses and of course for as well as Ted
lasso and the 11 time Emmy award-winning
hit show now in its third season at
Apple TV plus Jason Sudeikis welcome to
the show thank you for having me how are
you around spicy food before we get
started if it has like three little
jalapenos next to it at a restaurant
I'll I'll give it a shot oh you're
adventurous I'll give it a shot yeah yes
so yeah doesn't mean um
especially if I'm not paying you know
we'll go for it I got good news for you
Jason wings of death on the table and
they're on us today are you ready to get
started kind of you yes yes I am yes sir
[Music]
I think you kind of gotta go for it
I mean yeah very straightforward
Classics for a table Diner hot sauce
there yeah yeah exactly there you go
yeah you're eating this you're
surrounded by about 50 to 60 television
screens
okay yeah the games are on yeah exactly
right very approachable yep
[Music]
so I likewise grew up in the midwest
playing sports and I can see Ted lasso
and a lot of the baseball and football
coaches that I had growing up were you
inspired by any coaches in particular or
is Ted lasso more of an amalgamation
it's an amalgamation of a bunch of
different you know teachers mentors uh
you know um whether people I actually
got to meet or or work alongside of or
be coached by but then you know certain
elements of it uh the look was kind of
inspired by Mike Ditka you know having
the shades and the short polyester
shorts and the mustache was was very
much Ditka
um then I had my high school basketball
coach Phil named Donnie Campbell you
know it would you know do those little
turns of phrases like Ted does
um and you know and I always love those
things and he also was the one that
really pretty much introduced myself and
my teammates to John Wooden who was the
UCLA basketball coach that that has a
bunch of phrases that are more like
philosophical than you know pop culture
or or like quirky and whatnot but yeah
it's so it's an amalgamation of all
those things
[Music]
to show your idea so
Chris Schoenberger who's not here right
now
he was the one that was like well what
if we interviewed celebrities but had me
increasingly spicy chicken wings over
the course of the interview is a way to
break them down yeah and then here we
are it's become like the cross I bear
you know like eight seasons later just
eating hot sauce eating wings didn't
know this would happen but here we are
yeah I mean that's
I think I think if people know that that
stuff's gonna happen they're lying right
right what happens you just want to hope
that you're prepared to like deal with
the good and the bad that comes with
something that just hold on to the board
and the Title Wave takes over and
wherever it goes It goes you just try to
stay on it you like water
yeah I mean that was nice too there we
go that's that's nothing to worry about
here nothing to worry about it's not
yeah I mean yeah all right
you don't get the 21 Seasons when
there's not a little something to worry
about all right I've watched Jeopardy
you know all right I've seen The
Simpsons man I know what's up uh yeah so
you hear a lot about influential acting
teachers stanislavski Meisner and the
effect that they've had on Hollywood but
I'm curious what role do you think
comedy instructors like Dell close have
played in shaping American humor oh
goodness
I mean unquantifiable I mean you know I
mean I was lucky to have Dell close for
for one year and he was it was very you
know during my time in Chicago in the
late 90s and it's not just him it's then
also the like the I believe it's called
like the the Pyramid of influence like
like the people that he influenced it
then how they influenced and how they
influenced because like the Andy Reid
coaching tree or something yeah is that
is that a term yeah yeah but yeah like
we're like he was influenced by this
coach and this coach like we run this
play but we run this version of it all
that yeah that's exactly what it is
because you know hopefully you get to do
enough of it that your influences get
rubbed off like sort of get beaten out
of you so I mean I think every dude
around you know my age I'm 47 I don't
know how old you are you know 36 yeah so
like like probably you know plus or
minus like five years of me like
everybody did Jim Carrey at some point
you know and then at some point it kind
of gets you know either beaten out of
your weaned out of you and it just
becomes part of your spine you know
those like yeah you know I'm probably
constantly ripping off Bugs Bunny and
not even realizing it so yeah they'll
close some Bugs Bunny those are
for everyone not just me
crabby shark
sounds familiar
yummy as well
clean up that thing yeah man throw them
down I love it I like I like half of a
half of a turkey sandwich which is
actually the way to do it that's the way
to do it that's the way to do it you
don't want to overeat and then come into
this yeah I don't want my stomach to be
all small I want to have like a little
yeah little room a little room and you
know a Baseline
yeah
[Music]
so I've heard you say that before you
were hired on Saturday Night Live you
hated on it as a young comedy lover
which is something that I understand but
I think that like you and Bob Odenkirk
are like the only people that have heard
admit that out loud how would you I take
that I'd take pride in that like that's
great I mean Bob I love that dude how
would you unpackage that sentiment the
metaphorically it feels a little bit
like you know the girl in school that
you have a crush on uh that you kind of
hate on until you realize oh that's
weird that you feel that way because she
was asking about you it's like really
what did she ask yeah I was gonna be
careful don't get it but but
because it was just
just a little bit of that youthful
ignorance and arrogens you know they
would never let me play you know
football and Notre Dame I'd never get to
play basketball KU but you know so what
you know how would I ever get to you
know do this like work on Saturday Night
Live so yeah let's hang on and it wasn't
so much hating on it was like because
because I had Heroes on that show I had
friends on that show at that time I had
a specific reason why I or that I tried
to articulate why but I think deep down
inside it was just you know protecting
myself from the the possibility of not
achieving something that boy boy
wouldn't need wouldn't be neat if I did
you know
well that's sweet at first oh
are you just immune to it no
so I'm no superhero right you know like
I feel it all but I think the difference
is I don't panic because I've been there
you know what I mean like they come in
and this is like the spiciest meal
they've ever eaten in their life and
then they're doing it in this ridiculous
context of like
lights and cameras and strangers oh wait
a minute you know right yeah yeah so I
feel it I feel it it gets uncomfortable
sometimes have any of your reactions to
this on this show become a meme or a gif
yeah well one time I almost died on my
shield on the show here actually with uh
John Bernthal yup the first Wing yeah I
take a bite and then I don't know what
happened but I took like a little breath
in like I think he said something that
made me laugh a little bit and a piece
of chicken got lodged like clean in my
windpipe and I went to talk and I was
like like it was like coming out like
and then I started because I'd never
felt anything like that and the thought
started to go into my head like this
will be my legacy you know the chicken
wing talk show host that choked on a
drumstick and went out on his shield
with John Bernthal sitting across from
him so that was a moment that I had so
when people go through that how'd you
get out of it what happened did you
heimlich yourself or what happened I was
about to and then Dom over there was
getting concerned started creeping up
and I was and then you have that sort of
like everyone's like you know what I
mean like not only am I going out but
I'm going out in like this way where
everyone's like looking at me and I'm
helpless I'm trying to explain it to him
but I can't so uh but anyways it just
naturally kind of like cleared like by
the grace of God or something you know
and then my body just taking care of the
next like two or three wings like I was
kind of talking like this though
[Music]
that's nice
yeah right so the premise of Ted lasso
naturally invites an interesting
reflection on the differences between
American and British comedy now I know
this is kind of a silly exercise but I
am curious how do you think a British
comedy about an Englishman taking over
an NFL franchise how do you think that
might be different in tone from what
you've created with Ted lasso um
mm-hmm
I mean you know the Wardrobe hugely
different you know they might be in like
a nice suit they're you know just you
know like they do dress nice I would
imagine a huge annoyance at having to
speak at the quarter and halftime to the
Press right yeah when I see the NBA
coaches have to like you know like okay
she's doing quarters yeah like the
game's going on what are you gonna do
what are you what are you gonna surprise
these guys with next half on this don't
they have TNT are they gonna hear this
like come on man uh so I mean there's
probably some element of that probably
they might they might get a little
annoyed with our lack of clever chance
over here I can see the British coach
writing the chance for the crowd be like
here you know like here go ahead and do
this but yeah you know those are a few
ideas right something like that that all
sounds good to me no all right Jason are
you ready to move on here to the back
half yes oh yeah yeah here we are here
we are
I know I'm so used to the wings coming
in a dozen that this 10 is like it's
light work yeah you know we've two you
know one one for him one for him you
know right
this reminds me
[Music]
at this movie hall pass it was yeah and
with me and Owen Wilson but then also
you know Steve Merchant
um JB Smoove Larry Joe Campbell and we
did a scene taking place at a sports bar
and we're eating wings and was my first
time of being in like a big Studio Movie
like like Elite like like Owen and I are
on the poster type thing and we're going
around and we shoot like all people
around the thing you you know you have
to keep moving the camera
you have the time and money which they
usually do for Studio movies and there
are hot wings and I just made you know
and they weren't this hot for not as hot
as the one we just had yeah yeah it's
the new level by the way yeah I was
about to say like as you were just going
through that I was like wow you just uh
right over that speedboat no problem no
no no it's this happened
yeah we're in real time here yeah
what's that saying I'm an actor right
okay here's what I know so we're uh
we're eating these wings and I'm eating
them while the camera's on like Owen
they tell you not to eat you know I know
well but you were if they didn't before
them I I didn't you know I hadn't done
enough to have my method
and at some point I'm eating them and
and he's just saying God
[Music]
so you you don't spawn anything in your
body huh and I'm like I'm like oh yeah
he goes I'd be so curious what you look
like if you actually worked out and took
care of yourself
this one just has a little signer at the
bottom I was saying very hot
very hot
but an otherwise kind of like nice and
approachable label yeah but then the
heat on this sauce
no is this one that I'm gonna be talking
all of a sudden I'm gonna be yeah going
forward that's how it goes you know
because a lot of times I'll see you guys
like oh that wasn't that bad but then it
has that sort of like 30 second time
release okay right yep and then it kind
of just waves on us right from there it
was great this is yeah this is here we
go this is the fun yeah I mean it's been
enjoyable speaking with you and I really
enjoy you know but now you really feel
it doesn't feel it that's why you know
way too then yeah that's why I put the
pay-per-view uh paywall up right here
for this moment right here
so early in your career I know it was a
dream of yours to join the Blue Man
Group auditioning at least three
different times what's the process like
for turning yourself blue like how long
does it take and then do you remember
the initial reaction your first reaction
upon seeing yourself in the mirror for
the first time oh yeah yeah I mean the
process I only got to get bald and blue
they say one time now here's the thing
that I didn't realize is that all these
guys had different faces than me they
all were like great looking like
cheekbones like a full set of Choppers
they're not like like it just looks
different and then when you are all one
color
if you don't have those things to hang
that paint on you look like I did which
I sincerely mean this and I like I look
like a blue peanut m m it was just it
was like it was like that's not a face
in there anymore it's like eyes and some
little tiny teeth but there's no I can't
see it I can't see a hint of cheekbones
I don't know what the hell is going on
there and I did not look like my cool
ass buddies you know I was like oh no
and then you know the drumming just with
the intensity of being in the thing and
all that my chops weren't strong enough
so it's like I I went in there and I
remember just like flop sweating you
know and then your flap swinging and
then blue in the blue yeah in the blue
and it's just and you know just a blue m
m just you know getting rinsed with like
a garden hose oh yeah real Tears of a
Clown yeah absolutely yeah a blue clown
no less oh well I'm here now well
speaking of crying yes this next sauce
is the bomb Beyond Insanity yep is this
where's this from I guess Kansas City
baby that's right that's how I know him
you know yeah yeah
that's just a cough that's not a
preemptive cough yeah it's clearing it
out
I'm preparing it all right here we go
let's go Casey Kansas City Kansas PS
This is the side I'm from you know for
those that care for the distinction
foreign
[Music]
yeah what the hell yeah oh Lord
yeah man and there's two more evidence
there's two more I'm just reminding you
yeah
oh
different level altogether let's talk
about our viewing yeah let's do it let's
do it
yeah man that's crazy I know this is
like this is one everybody talks about
but yeah it really is it it lives up to
the yeah to the legend I guess it does
okay so on the topic of Kansas City I
actually got to participate my first
ever big slick last oh you did I did I
did you were filming of course in London
the charity event that you guys do every
year to benefit Children's Mercy
Hospital yes and let me tell you what
you missed out on all right please
because at the end there's this Buffet
the sprawling Buffet of pulled pork and
burnt ends and spare ribs from all these
different from all of the different
places yeah Kansas City Barbecue City
you know surrounds us and supports it
yeah how would you describe your ideal
Kansas City Barbecue crawl oh
I mean it's hard man it's it's like it's
like I I I I I want I want burnt ends
you know from uh
say Gates I'll tell you I'll take you
know pulled pork from Kansas City Joe's
I'll take you know any of the sides from
Jack Stack I'll do you know
q39 for uh
well the the turkey and then I'll do my
brisket from Arthur Bryant's there you
go and then the sauce that you just ate
from Kansas City after trying it would
you consider that like a point of Pride
or an Abomination I think it's
absolutely pointed price there we go
that's why look I mean I I I I I I was
pretty sure it was but I didn't look
before we started but um absolute point
of Pride you know it's a great name it's
a frightening bottle
there's a nuclear warhead on it and a
disgusting sauce but you know the
disgusting sauce the hurts your mouth
and probably your stomach and butthole
in just a matter of moments
now this one a watermelon ghost like
this sounds nice
put the watermelon back yeah
strange hot sauce this one I gotta say
nope
no there's another one of those little
signs down at the bottom so there's
extreme heat
there's all this stuff to look at and
read
then down there extreme heat yeah I know
but then they kind of lead with the
watermelon you know there's a lot of
mixed messages with extremely hot hot
sauce yes you know some of it sometimes
they don't really like tell you like
they don't reach out and scream to you
like this is super [__] hot yeah they
don't put a nuclear warhead without
caution just only the ones with
Integrity you know
I am who I claim to be
all right
kind of fishing here but do you have a
favorite Norm Macdonald story those are
up there with like Michael Jordan lore
like I just can't get enough I I do and
I know he's told this story before and I
think Seth has told the story but this
is but this happened to me in real time
where we then go to I was staying in a
hotel he's like hey uh you hungry I was
like I was like yeah I'm staying at the
sunset Tower he goes oh yeah greatly
we'll go go uh you know have some
breakfast it was like you know 11 A.M or
so so I was like absolutely so we're
sitting there we're just talking about
what not
and he goes he's like hey I uh
you always showing my son you know uh
some of my old uh stuff you know when I
was on Saturday Night Live there and I
was like yeah yeah I know he goes you
know like doing the news thing like yeah
and he goes uh remember one point I
showed to my kid and uh
and he goes oh Dad you uh you you do
your jokes just like Seth and I was like
oh no my son doesn't know how time works
and I was just like sitting there like
like did he just come up with that was
this all a ruse I was doing Seth's show
right after Norm had passed and two days
before I got there Seth told that story
so he had you know Norman then shared
that story with multiple people at that
point whether it was Rift or not or told
or set up and just to you know for that
punch line to knock me out the way it
did was one of those things about him
that I just love he was just always he
always wanted to make you laugh but he
but he but not work too hard while doing
it it's such a badass way to go about
doing it and in being that way he just
he continues he's one of those guys you
can just watch forever and just you know
you can't help but wishing you kind of
talked like him you know
here we are all right let's shake this
one you gotta shake it
all right what happens if he's known you
know what that's a good question I have
no idea I have no idea
[Music]
how much did you put on I actually did
the good dab usually I end up
accidentally just dumping it like crazy
there you go good job
all right cheers Jason cheers all right
[Music]
it had a hair on it but the the the dab
uh disintegrated so we're fine
[Music]
I mean I came right after that dab too
but I don't know what the hell I'm
thinking you know
I put it right on my tongue same with me
what
I took it head on yup
oh
because that's what it's about
meeting the moment you know I feel like
this whole thing would have been easier
we did it with our eyes closed
never done one of these in the dark no
but that actually you know now the mind
is turning you know sensory deprivation
the hot ones kind of episode absolutely
or upside down
zero gravity hot ones is what we need to
be doing
Season 22 Yeah but I love the rewrite
table I love the reasons no idea is a
bad idea this is what we do they're
expensive they're more expensive it does
increase the value of the uh of the
program
um cost
um so when we had David Blaine on the
show he talked about how he'll often
mess up a trick right while it's
happening but that he can usually fix it
on the Fly because he knows where the
trick ends up yeah and the audience is
usually none the wiser yes all right so
as a lifelong magic hobbyist yourself
I'm curious do you see any sort of
connection or similarity between
magicians and improv performers and then
follow up I brought a deck of cards I'm
not going to ask you to do a card trick
but I am curious if you can do one of
your like showman pops with your
fingertips and brain soaked in hot sauce
you know there's an added degree of
difficulty here yeah it's funny because
when you open this it did make me feel
like oh this is like what a magician you
know card in person does you know
they'll be like hey brand new deck let's
do this so you know what it's like man I
know you can buy those stickers
um
um as far as this stuff you know there
are folks I can do
far greater stuff than me I can do a cut
like a couple a couple of things but I
think the thing you're talking about
let's bring it up and so I think I've
done this in a handful of movies and
whatnot yeah and then you just sit there
and and yeah and that's that and then
yeah you can do one handy cut you know
stuff like that wow but but that's one
thing man people magicians ice in their
veins like to have to like do something
to perform something like athletes
magicians man that's a different breed
to what to want to do that to be able to
do that big UPS Jason Sudeikis
taking on the wings of death indeed look
at you ten toes in the sand taking on
the wings of death going back with the
Kansas City come on
yeah oh my gosh the bomb
what a way to go out all right that's
another magic trick right there Jason
Sudeikis can't feel anything and with
that remember it's all done it's all
done roll credits this camera this
camera or this camera let the people
know what you have going on in your life
um yeah I'm just dealing with it with uh
the hubris of going back to the mom I
mean it's a little Hometown Pride but
then also a a nice chunk of hubris too
shouldn't have done that don't know why
I did that could have left on a make oh
well um but yeah that's that's about it
you know we got we got uh yeah right
what did I do that for
thank you
this is great man and your questions are
so I mean I knew that going in and
that's part of the reason I think people
you get such uh um
you know such a a wide breath and you
know a punch above our weight class yeah
sure absolutely but it's like just very
thoughtful questions and playful
questions thank you thank you but yeah
man that's great it's such a it's I'm
I always like the the uh I think it does
come from starting an improv like where
it was all suggestion based you know
like who runs in any way where it's all
about getting out of the pickle that
they put you in it's not just like take
one suggestion then make art yeah it's
kind of like people trying to like get
in your way
but you know what they couldn't get in
your way they couldn't get in your way
boss no I mean that last one did I'm
telling you it was stupid
no reason to do it
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans if you've ever watched hot
ones and wondered to yourself how hot
are those sauces really I could get
through that with no water or milk well
now is the time to put your money where
your mouth is the hot ones season 21
lineup is now available in its entirety
at heatness.com heatness.com that's
heatness.com to get your hands on the
season 21 hot Ones hot sauce lineup milk
not included be careful around the eyes
and get them while they're hot
mother